[Musique]
bonsoir les petites annonces as tu eu
raison d'apporter des bonbons à nicolas
et pimprenelle mais comme sol ne se
disputeront plus pas trop j'espère que
tu dis vrai parce que ce n'est pas beau
des enfants qui se disputent soyez sans
crainte cela ne se reproduira plus je
vous le garantis et hop pour les châles
pop hip hop hop hop hop hop hop hop on
bosse
si l'on y en a nicolas g un pur pape
rebelles si elle ne taquine plus son
frère
tenez là
je sais bien que les petites filles et
les petits garçons aiment bien les
pompons
n'est-ce pas nicolas
[Musique]
je suis un petit garçon de bella figura
tu veux mieux le pompon et les
confitures
c'est vont fouler m'a donné je sens et
bien les manger la bonaventure guînes la
peña monture a dû
lorsque les petits garçons sont gentils
et sage on leur donne des bonbons de
jolies images
mais quand ils se font gronder la flèche
trop leur donner l'autre davanture ok le
triste aventure
je serai sage et bien bon pour plaire à
ma mère je
serai bien ma leçon pour plaire à mon
père je veux bien les contenter et s'ils
veulent embrasser la bonne aventure on
dit la panne a menti
ans
où
non
[Musique]
et bien tant pis je ne cache pas mes
bonbons moi je cache pas les miennes et
voilà ceux de nicolas que j'avais caché
pour toi non
c'est vrai gic alors merci nicolas et
bien tout est bien qui finit bien
c'est à elle de
bonnes ni le
banni les noces
panis-nicolas car bien fait pour elle
petite soeur
[Musique]
patron regardez encore des bonbons oui
mais c'est nicolas qui me les a données
vous en voulez oui nounours l'on se très
vilain d'être gourmand je les mettrai
sur ma table de nuit allons en route non
bon nounours bonne et des enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents ne
mangez pas trop de bobo est fait pour
[Musique]